[Música]
eeuu el reino unido australia y bélgica
aconsejaron a quienes intentan ingresar
al aeropuerto de kabul para ser
evacuados desalojar el área debido a una
alta amenaza terrorista por parte de
militantes del grupo de estado islámico
pese a esto los afganos permanecen a las
inmediaciones desesperados por huir
aumenta a 20 el número de personas
fallecidas por las lluvias registradas
en el estado de mérida al oeste de
venezuela según las autoridades al menos
17 personas se encuentran desaparecidas
y unos 54 mil ciudadanos han resultado
afectados el presidente de nicolás
maduro decretó el estado de emergencia
en brásil miles de indígenas siguen
esperando a las afueras de la sede del
tribunal supremo- la histórica decisión
sobre el futuro de sus tierras el fallo
que se suponía iba a ser anunciado ayer
ni siquiera empezó el presidente de ayr
bolsonaro ha manifestado abiertamente su
deseo de fomentar el desarrollo rural en
esos territorios ancestrales
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 su regla que como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
en afganistán donde eeuu reino unido
australia y bélgica pidieron a quienes
intentan ingresar al aeropuerto de kabul
para ser evacuados despejar la zona
debido a la alta amenaza terrorista por
parte del grupo estado islámico
sin embargo enormes multitudes siguen en
las afueras y a las puertas de esta
terminal aérea en medio del caos y en un
intento por alcanzar un vuelo para salir
de afganistán dominado ahora por los
talibanes según informó el secretario de
estado estadounidense el talibán se
comprometió a dejar salir del país a
extranjeros y afganos en riesgo tras el
retiro total de las tropas para el 31 de
agosto y por su parte james hippie l
ministro de las fuerzas armadas
británicas aseguró que están trabajando
en la búsqueda de rutas de seguridad
para las personas que desean desalojar y
reiteró la amenaza terrorista
no puedo compartir con ustedes el
detalle exacto de cuál es la amenaza
pero lo que sí puedo decir es que en el
transcurso de la semana la credibilidad
de los reportes ha llegado a un punto en
el que creemos que hay una amenaza muy
inminente y altamente letal de un
posible ataque dentro de kabul y como
consecuencia hemos tenido que cambiar
las recomendaciones de viaje y aconsejar
a las personas que no vayan al
aeropuerto de hecho que se alejen del
aeropuerto busquen un lugar seguro y
esperen más instrucciones
vamos hasta agua quads en reino unido
con nuestra corresponsal lisa pulido
luisa muy buen día que detalles se
conocen hasta el momento sobre la
amenaza del atentado a las afueras del
aeropuerto internacional de kabul
son un pocos hasta el momento por
supuesto pero el reino unido se ha
sumado a esta alerta emitida por eeuu de
la inminencia de un posible ataque
terrorista en afganistán
el objetivo principal sería el
aeropuerto internacional de kabul donde
recordemos se encuentran desde hace
varios días miles y miles de personas
esperando su turno para poder salir del
país o también otro objetivo serían los
centros occidentales de atención a los
migrantes que están o podrían salir de
ese país el atentado sería perpetrado o
de autoría del estado islámico del
corazón como ustedes lo han escuchado el
ministro de defensa británico dijo
además que este atentado podría ser
cuestión de horas y ha pedido a los
ciudadanos británicos que abandonen
inmediatamente este perímetro del
aeropuerto internacional de kabul por
supuesto esta alerta emitida por eeuu
ayer y replicada por el reino unido hoy
pasado en toda la información de
inteligencia que tienen
que permite y hace más difícil la
evacuación humanitaria de todas estas
personas que están esperando repito hace
varios días en medio de esta crisis
humanitaria que vive afganistán para
poder ser evacuados de ese país hablemos
de ese punto de vista porque el reino
unido lidera con eeuu la misión de
evacuación humanitaria cuáles son las
últimas cifras que se tienen hasta el
momento
el ministro de las fuerzas militares
advirtió hoy que la ventana para la
evacuación humanitaria se está empezando
a cerrar el reino unido tiene
organizados 11 vuelos para las próximas
24 horas pero no sabemos a qué punto
esta alerta de un posible atentado
terrorista puede afectar esos planes de
evacuar más personas de afganistán no
solamente ciudadanos británicos que se
encuentran en ese terreno sino también a
todas las personas nacionales de
afganistán que sirvieron como
intérpretes en estos 20 años de guerra
en ese país de ocupación el primer
ministro boris johnson ha hablado hace
pocos minutos a los medios británicos y
ha dicho que 15 mil personas han sido
evacuados por las tropas británicas y ha
prometido además que todas las personas
que son elegibles para salir de ese país
lo harán en las próximas horas pero
recordemos el reloj va corriendo para
que llegue a esa fecha en cinco días del
31 de agosto cuando se cumple la fecha
límite dada por dos unidos para la
retirada de las tropas de ese país y
entonces las tropas occidentales pero
desafortunadamente ya el gobierno
británico ha advertido que todas las
personas no podrán salir de afganistán
especialmente quienes no están en kabul
lamentable y dura la situación en
afganistán y luisa muchísimas gracias
por su informe de ese reino unido- este
jueves el presidente estadounidense joe
biden recibirá al primer ministro
israelí naftalí bennett en la casa
blanca en la que será su primera reunión
cara a cara el tema central será iraní
las amenazas que según israel plantea la
república islámica a la seguridad
regional y a quien considera su
principal enemigo en la zona también
abordarán la situación regional en
oriente medio' cuestiones del conflicto
palestino-israelí la relación de israel
con el liderazgo palestino o la
influencia de china en el estado judío
y tres veces después de la guerra de 11
días de israel en contra del grupo de
islamista hamás que dejó cientos de
muertos hoy a decenas de personas sin
hogar los residentes de casas sigan
esperando ayuda para la reconstrucción
un informe de la onu la unión europea y
el banco mundial estima que se necesitan
más de 400 millones de dólares para
reparar todos los años
en este barrio de gasa los trabajos de
remoción de escombros continúan los
obreros activan sus excavadoras pero los
esfuerzos son enormes allí un edificio
entero se cayó en un ataque aéreo
israelí
tres meses después de la guerra el
enclave palestino intenta reconstruirse
y la desesperación se apodera de las
víctimas
si mañana comienza a llover qué vamos a
hacer el invierno se acerca y tenemos
que reconstruir nuestras casas no
queremos dinero sino que vengan a
arreglar todo esto
muchas familias de la zona temen revivir
la misma situación que en 2014 donde la
ofensiva israelí dejó un paisaje de
devastación la reconstrucción duró años
después de las destrucciones ni siquiera
recibimos 100 dólares de su parte
solo tendrían que haber venido hasta
constatar los daños ellos mismos
para reconstruir las rutas los
hospitales y las habitaciones dañadas
elicabe necesita al menos 400 85
millones de dólares
todas sus esperanzas se encuentran
actualmente en los países de la región
esperamos que se abran las fronteras con
el fin de hacer entrar los fondos para
la reconstrucción
egipto se comprometió a enviar 500
millones de dólares qatar también
prometió 500 millones de dólares y otros
países deberían enviar ayuda como kobe
tanto y arabia saudita la última
escalada del conflicto tuvo un enorme
impacto sobre la economía de la franja
de gaza y sus 2 millones de habitantes
las pérdidas se calculan alrededor de
los 200 millones de dólares cambiamos
ahora información y del continente
continuamos en venezuela donde al menos
20 personas han muerto por los
deslizamientos ocasionados a raíz de las
fuertes lluvias que afectan
principalmente al estado de mérida desde
el lunes de esta semana el presidente
nicolás maduro declaró el estado de
emergencia por tres meses para los cinco
estados más impactados veamos el informe
bar y aclara calle
más de 20 personas han muerto a causa de
las fuertes lluvias en venezuela el
municipio más afectado es sucre del
estado de mérida en el noroeste del país
tal como lo explicó el protector de la
región jason guzmán probablemente hay
que informarle al presidente que hemos
tenido ayer cuando le pase a la
empatamos el informe teníamos un reporte
de 15 personas fallecidas ese este
número creció durante el día de hoy ha
llegado a un número de 20 personas
fallecidas hoy nos reportaron personas
fallecidas en el sector y ahora en el
municipio sucre guzmán afirmó que los
daños son muy considerables y no dio más
detalles también señaló que continúan
con las labores de rescate y
levantamiento de escombros pero no es el
único estado ha afectado los deslaves
también están impactando en apure
bolívar yaracuy y zulia de hecho el
presidente nicolás maduro firmó un
decreto de emergencia por 90 días para
todos estos estados actualmente estoy
aprobando los recursos suficientes
innecesario
en bolívares en cripto moneda y en
divisas convertibles todos los recursos
que le haga falta a mérida para que
ustedes actúen con la mayor contundencia
y resultado desde lunes de esta semana
ha habido deslizamientos en la sierra
ubicada a orillas del desbordado río
mocotíes en el estado de mérida y el
instituto nacional de metereología e
hidrología advirtió que se espera que
las lluvias continúen en los próximos
días y se espera que finalmente este
jueves el tribunal supremo de brasil
responda a una apelación histórica para
los pueblos indígenas sobre la
delineación de sus territorios los
pueblos originarios se mostraron
frustrados por el hecho de que la corte
no empezará a debatir el caso el día
miércoles veamos
es un momento crucial y se saca la
decisión de la corte suprema- fue
aplazada hasta este jueves unos 6000
indígenas de 170 etnias ataviados con
sus coloridas vestimentas tradicionales
resisten en los improvisados campamentos
bajo el lema lucha por la vida y es que
el futuro de sus territorios y
comunidades ancestrales dependen del
fallo grandes propietarios y aliados de
jair bolsonaro quieren legalizar el
despojo a los indígenas impidiendo el
reconocimiento legal de sus tierras si
no estaban físicamente allí en
1988 incluso si los habían expulsado
el máximo tribunal de brasilia debe
decidir sobre el denominado marco
temporal por el que los pueblos
originarios de brasil sólo tendrían
derecho a la tierra si estaban habitando
la antes de 1988 cuando se ratificó la
constitución del país para los
activistas y nativos la norma supondría
una nueva expropiación de su territorio
en la amazonía que durante décadas se ha
visto amenazado tanto por la
colonización como las guerras y más
recientemente la feroz deforestación
y queremos cuidar nuestros territorios
nuestros mayores y niños por eso estamos
en brasilia para obtener algún
reconocimiento porque la gente no nos
reconoce como verdaderos brasileños por
eso ocupamos recibiã hoy para mostrarle
a brasil y al mundo que no morimos
estamos vivos y somos la historia viva
de brasil
los activistas dicen que la decisión de
la corte podría ser el fallo del ciclo y
el posible desplazamiento de las
comunidades de sus resguardos que será
un duro golpe para el mantenimiento de
la selva amazónica y cuyo papel es clave
frente a la lucha contra el cambio
climático
y miren ustedes esta noticia después de
tres décadas el bebé que aparece desnudo
en la portada el icónico álbum de la
banda nirvana nevermind presentó una
demanda por explotación sexual infantil
una batalla que según algunos expertos
carece de sustento
30 años después de su lanzamiento
nevermind el álbum de la banda nirvana
sigue siendo uno de los éxitos más
importantes de todos los tiempos un
icónico álbum que marcó una generación
entera pero nadie más que aspen xerente
luego de tres décadas quien vuelve de la
portada dice haber sufrido daños de por
vida por lo que presentó una demanda por
explotación sexual
es preocupante saber que toda esa gente
vio mi pene de cuando era bebé
aouate pau game una vez estuve en un
partido de béisbol y en un momento fue
como hey todas estas personas vieron mi
pene de bebé sin mantener el den está
pidiendo 150.000 dólares de cada uno de
sus acusados entre los que están en
universal music group las leyendas
musicales dave crowe y kornílov al igual
que el fotógrafo que tomó la fotografía
original
ahora muchos expertos legales son
escépticos sobre si la foto puede
considerarse como pornografía infantil
no parece haber una conducta sexual solo
porque la foto muestra un niño desnudo
no significa que sea pornografía
infantil
en ese entonces nirvana era una banda
relativamente poco conocida muy lejos
del éxito mundial que obtuvieron unos
años después el fotógrafo kirk weddle
dijo que le pagaron mil dólares mientras
que los padres de eulen que eran sus
amigos sólo recibieron 200 dólares por
la foto
alden que tiene tatuado el nombre del
álbum en su pecho ha posado en repetidas
ocasiones para recrear el icónico álbum
mejor recordemos nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para que siempre esté
informado con nosotros ahí estamos
titulando el eso ese que lanza naciones
unidas para ayudar a las víctimas del
terremoto de haití esta y otras noticias
usted como siempre las puedo ampliar en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
también por supuesto a la espera lo que
ocurre en brasil con las tierras de los
indígenas
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continue con nosotros muy
buen día para todos
[Música]